الى قطاع غزه وهذه الصور والدخان اعمده
الدخان جديده تتصاعد على ما يبدو غار
اسرائيليه جديده هبه لا تزالين معنا لا
ادري ان كنت تسمعيننا هل من تعليق على هذه
الصور
نعم هي غارات جديده متتاليه تقريبا ثلاثه
غارات كانت احداها في شمال مدينه غزه هذه
الادخنه التي تشاهدونها تتصاعد في هذه
المنطقه وايضا هناك غار في منطقه شمال بيت
لاهيا شمال قطاع غزه وغاره ثالثه الى
الشرق من جباليا هذه الغارات خلال دقائق
معدوده كانت متتاليه ثلاث غارات ولكن ايضا
في هذه الوقت شاهدنا ايضا انطلاق تقريبا
صاروخين من قطاع غزه باتجاه اراضي الداخل
المحتل
واراضي الاسرائيليه
هذه
الصواريخ التي صعدت ايضا شاهدنا انطلاق
صواريخ من القبه الحديديه في سماء منطقه
شمال قطاع غزه في شمال بيت حانون نشاهد
هذه
القذائف من القبه الحديديه تنفجر في سماء
المنطقه الشماليه من قطاع غزه وما زالت
ايضا السنه الدخان تنطلق من المناطق
الشمال شمال مدينه غزه شمال شرق مدينه غزه
هذه الغاره التي